hi
my name is Joan Stites I'm a professor
at Yale and what I'd like to tell you
about today is the importance of
serendipity in the discovery process in
science the story I'm going to be
telling you has to do with Smurfs which
are little particles inside all
ourselves that are the building blocks
of the spliceosome
which assembles on pre-messenger rnas to
remove the introns and make the
messenger RNA that can be translated by
the ribosome and these little snips as
you see in this slide have both RNA
molecules and protein molecules in them
the other way in which the story is
unusual is that it's definitely not a
bench-to-bedside story instead it's very
much a bedside to bench story where we
made use of something that physicians
had known about for a long time in order
to make discoveries about the basic
workings of cells so the story starts in
the early 1970s and at that time of
course we knew about the central dogma
we knew that DNA made RNA and RNA made
protein what we didn't know about was
introns or splicing people had worked
out many of the steps in gene expression
in bacterial cells and most people
thought that higher cells would be sort
of similar perhaps a little bit more
complicated but no new principles how
wrong we were what we did know in the
early 1970s was that there were several
things that were peculiar about higher
cells we knew that they had way too much
DNA a hundred to a thousand times more
than we thought they would need in order
to encode the number of genes that we
thought we had and the other thing was
that RNA lots of it got made in the
nucleus but about 90% of it got degraded
and only 10% of it ever made it out to
the cytoplasm
to be a messenger RNA so what was going
on and as a young assistant professor at
Yale I had studied RNA structure and
function in bacteria and bacteria phages
and I decided I wanted to take on this
problem on my first sabbatical leave we
knew that there were RNA binding
proteins inside mammalian cell nuclei
that immediately bound to the newly
synthesized messenger RNA and I thought
if I had antibodies against those
proteins I could use them as tools and
maybe this would help me figure out how
the cell decides which molecules to
degrade in which molecules to send out
to the cytoplasm its messenger RNAs so
for half a year I tried to make
antibodies against these nuclear RNA
binding proteins but this was without
success because these are very highly
conserved proteins and therefore very
non immunogenic so I gave up and did
something else for the rest of my
sabbatical but it was the year 1977 in
the summer that in France were
discovered evidence came together from
laboratories all over the world that
conclusively convinced everyone that our
genes in fact were not like bacterial
genes but contain segments of nonsense
the so called
introns and that these introns were then
spliced out once the entire gene was
made into pre messenger RNA and that was
what enabled the cell to send a
fully-formed message to the cytoplasm to
be translated by the ribosomes so the
question then was what is a cellular
machinery that very precisely recognizes
the ends of the introns and allows the
splicing process to be exact when I went
back to my lab in the fall of 1977
everybody wanted to work on this process
we were in RNA lab but frankly we were
pretty clueless about what we should do
next and then came the first piece of
serendipity in January of 1978 a new
issue of the journal Nature arrived in
the lab with this rather complicated
but the important point was the
underlined sentence here which says that
patients with mctv mixed connective
tissue disease have antibodies against
nuclear RNA protein complexes and this
caught my attention because while I was
trying to make antibodies and failing
several people had said that they
thought they'd heard of some diseases
where patients made Auto antibodies
antibodies against their own cellular
components that reacted with nuclear RNA
protein complexes at that time I had in
the lab a new md PhD student like a
learner he was fresh from his medical
school courses and I said Michael do you
know anybody here at Yale Medical School
who might have patients with these
diseases and he said sure I'll go see
Harden harden was right across the
street in the Rheumatology section and
that very afternoon Michael came back
with several small vials of serum from
patients with suspected auto antibodies
no the sobering part of this story is if
this were to happen today one would have
to spend weeks if not months filling out
human investigation forms getting it
through committees in order to use even
just a few milliliters of serum from a
patient in an experiment so this
probably never would have happened but
in any case Michael started working with
these sera and the idea was that the
auto antibodies would then recognize the
cellular component and we would use them
as tools to both characterize the to
purify and to characterize the function
of the target of the auto antibodies and
here what you see in this picture is the
idea that maybe RNA was in there and
protein as well and we now know that
those were snaps and that patients with
lupus and other autoimmune diseases
often make antibodies against nerves
however the going was rough as Michael
purified the cellular component kept
disappearing we now know because
ribonuclease we
in the preparations and kept eating away
at the RNA component and then the second
piece of serendipity happened and this
was a seminar visit by Joan brookie who
is now professor at Harvard Medical
School and she came and talked about a
new reagent called protein a that she
was using to capture immune complexes
made with lice eighths of virus infected
cells and antibodies against those
proteins and the advantage of that was
it could be done very fast and you could
also look at radioactively-labeled cell
lysate and what we see here is that on
the very far side is the total RNA is in
a nuclear extract of HeLa cells labeled
with P 32 going from the very small ones
at the bottom about 70 nucleotides long
up to u2 which is about 200 nucleotides
long
Michael's own serum which was used as
the control in the next Lane
immunoprecipitated
no rnase but what you see on the
right-hand side here is the pattern that
he obtained with various different auto
antibodies from various patients and for
the first time we could see what the
RNAs were and then we could also use
this to find out what the proteins were
in these little particles so what we now
know is that these very highly conserved
in very abundant targets of the auto
antibodies are in fact thus nerves that
by base pairing recognize specific
sequences in the pre messenger RNA
gather together with a lot of other
factors to form the spliceosome that
carries out the two-step reaction that's
involved in pre a messenger RNA splicing
to give finally the messenger RNA that
can be translated into protein this
isn't just test tube fiction here you
see a beautiful picture from an Byers
lab in Virginia showing DNA with nascent
RNA transcripts coming off it particles
building
at the 5-prime and 3-prime ends of an
intron coalescing to form a spliceosome
with the intron looped out which will
then shortly be removed by the actual
chemical process of splicing so what
I've told you is about how serendipity
and being interested in RNA protein
complexes in mammalian cells led to the
discovery of schnapps which contain SN
RNAs and proteins and how that process
is essential for making messenger RNAs
so these SN RNAs are in fact the first
non-coding rnas that we know to be
important in the regulation of gene
expression today we have micro RNA is
lots and lots of others and also as
we've understood about the splicing
process we know that splicing is the
reason why we can have the same number
of genes in our genome as the fruit fly
Drosophila and yet be more complicated
and this is because we do splicing in
alternative ways therefore making the
most out of every gene making multiple
products from every gene
you